après deux ans de pandémie les militants
pour l'environnement reprennent le
flambeau
max Sylvie et déçu du manque de courage
politique climatique qui la régle pas en
parlant d'économie verte c'est pas ça
c'est beaucoup plus profond que ça c'est
beaucoup plus dangereux que ça le pqs
sont présentés des plans approuvés par
des experts mais pour les manifestants
ce n'est pas assez même ces deux
parties-là ne vont pas assez loin notre
revendication c'est une sortie complète
du pétrole et du gaz d'ici 2030 est taxé
les plus riches pour financer le filet
social ce qui préoccupe pas également
c'est le fait que le parti qui risque de
former le prochain gouvernement
pratiquement pas pris dans un engagement
à la hauteur de ce qu'on lui demande
il est manifestant ont tenu à le dire au
ministre sortant de l'environnement venu
participer à la marche
[Applaudissements]
poursuivi par un certain nombre d'entre
eux Benoît charrette a été chassé avant
même que la manifestation ne commence
présent sur les lieux Gabriel Nadaud
Dubois a réagi la violence
l'intimidation les menaces à l'intégrité
physique des personnes c'est
inacceptable scander des slogans pour
dire on n'est pas d'accord avec vous ça
je pense que ça fait partie de la
liberté d'expression cette manifestation
est la plus importante depuis celle de
Greta Thunberg en septembre 2019 à
Montréal le mouvement écologiste avait
perdu de la vigueur avec la pandémie la
coalition souhaite raviver la flamme un
appel entendu par des milliers de
personnes aujourd'hui
ils étaient des centaines à Sherbrooke
Trois-Rivières Rimouski à Québec le
troisième guerre ne passe pas
à ottawaï Winnipeg leur message est
directement envoyé aux élus devant le
Parlement
bien qu'il se sente dans un dialogue de
sourd les militants persistent le
mouvement Fridays of future se
poursuivra tant que la lutte ne sera pas
gagnée ici Marie-José paquet como
Radio-Canada Montréal